>>BRIAN BOYLE AT THE NET FRONT
MALKIN SIZES ABOUT .
FORSBERG OUT OF THE PENALTY
BOX.
FORSBERG TR
THE ZONE.
TOMASINO FROM THE TOP.
RICOCHETED   SCORES!
THE HIGH SLOT, LETANG.
ONE MINUTE TO GOGO
HIM AND IT IS PICKED OFF BY
DUCHENE.
>> CHRIS: WATCH THIS PASS. .
LONG POSSESSION.
MALKIN TO THE
THE IMPORTANCE OF A FACE-OFF. S
THERE.
DESMITH HAS NO IDEA WHERE THAT
TOLVANEN, HE SCORES! TO
GUESS WHERHERE COMES  JEANNOT.
27 SECONDS TO GO.E STICK WAVE
THE PENGUINS PENALTY KILL HAS
BEEN SO RELIABLE. WATCH THIS SA
MALKIN. WAY
THAT HE'S ABLE TO
INSTANTANEOUSLY REACT TO THAT
DEFLECTION,  BREAKAWAY,
JOHANSEN FIGHTS HIS WAY UP THE
BOARD  WITH HIS POINT
STREAK GOING.RIGHT NOW
HE SCORES!GAME.
WATCH THIS RIGHT HERE.
JEANNOT OVER TO  JOSI. MATHESON
ANOTHER SAFER SAROS. THE